when I was in high school I went to a  commercial gym big dude was curling 40s  I went up to him and I started calling  him and the guy just smiled because he  knew what I didn't know which was it's  not about the weight on the bar the  weight of the muscle now almost 20 years  later I curl almost the same weight I  did that it's just the weight on my  muscle is 10 times more differentiate  between Lifting for ego or Lifting for  muscle it's just like an effort to  humility because when you do that though  if you build it back up the right way  and then you blow it pass but everyone  just gets stuck in the short term like I  want to see the weight on the bar go off  I want to see my Revenue go up but not  the quality of my business or my product